تحول الان الى نور الدين
استنادا لما قالته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
نور الدين فقد تحدثت عن قصف مركز للقياده
في بكره ماذا في التفاصيل
نعم ازدهار قبل ذلك دعيني اضعك في المشهد
الذي نحن فيه الان نحن في كييفسكي توجد
شمال دونيسك هنا سقطت ما يقارب او اكثر من
خمسه قذائف صاروخيه وكذلك قذائف مدفعيه
اذا ما لاحظنا هناك نلاحظ اثار للقذيفه
التي سقطت بهذا المكان هناك مجموعه من
القذائف التي سقطت بالاطراف هذا الحادث
الهجومي ادى الى سقوط قاتلين مع الاسف لا
يمكننا ان نظهر جثث احد القتلى الذي
يتواجد على اليسار والذي لم يتم نقله لحد
الساعه بحسب المعلومات المتوفره لدينا
فانه احد الصحفيين الذين يعملون هنا
بمدينه بالاضافه الى شخص اخر كما نشاهد
هنا الاثار اثار الدمار التي احدثها او
احدثتها هذه القذيفه هنا في هذا المكان
تكسر واجهات هذا هذه المنازل هنا والزجاج
بالاضافه الى وج قذيفه دخلت الى عمق احد
المنازل دون ان تنفجر ولا يزال الخطر
قائما ان تنفجر هذه القذيفه داخل ذلك
المنزل اذا هذه المدينه شهدت قبل قبل
لحظات سقوط هذا العدد من القذائف وهذا
يعكس سخونه الجبهه باعتبار ان هذه المنطقه
منطقه
مفتوحه على منطقه مواجهات في مارينكا
وكذلك باتجاه وهذا المجال يعطي حجم تبادل
اطلاق النار ما بين البلدين ما بين
القوتين القوات الاوكرانيه وكذلك القوات
الروسيه كما اشرت ازدهار بان الاستهداف
منطقه في في خركيب تابع في دنيتك تابع
للقوات الاوكرانيه هنا التبرير والتوجيه
العسكري لهذه المساله هو انه استهداف
لمركز قياده لماذا مركز قياده لان المناطق
الحدوديه لروسيا مع اوكرانيا اصبح يشكل
نوعا تهديدا للداخل الروسي خاصه مع وجود
قوات متمركزه هناك مع وجود طائرات مسيره
وكذلك وجود ذخيره للصواريخ ومركز القياده
والعمليات لذلك نلاحظ على ان القوات
الروسيه تركز كل مجهودها العسكري بشكل
كبير بالشمال والشمال الغربي من اجل منع
اي تحرك للقوات الاوكرانيه وكذلك دفع
القوات الاوكرانيه الى خطوط الدفاعيه اكثر
منها الى خطوط هجوميه ضرب مواقع اللوجستيك
والدعم للقوات الاوكرانيه من اجل احكام
السيطره على ما تبقى من دنيتك الى مارينكا
الى اوغليدار كما لاحظنا تغييرا في العمل
العسكري للقوات الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه
في جبهه وبالتحديد في جبهه جنوب دونيات
هناك محاوله لمنع اي تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه كفه خاصه في رباتنا هذه
المنطقه التي كانت تخضع لضغط شديد للقوات
الاوكرانيه الان تتحدث وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه والجيش الروسي على انه استطاع فك
هذا
في منطقه
استهدفنا مركز القياده المتقدم للمجموعه
الموحده للقوات الاوكرانيه كما تم تدمير
ثلاثه مستودعات ذخيره للمدفعيه قرب مدينه
زابروجيا وفي مناطقيف وفي اتجاه كوبيانسك
على مواقع مهمه بالقرب من قريه اورشانا
بخركيف ونجح الدفاعاتنا في صد تسع هجمات
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مناطق بلوغانسك